people make purchasing decisions based
on a prediction of future value meaning
a likelihood that it's going to deliver
what they want so what is the easiest
way to get someone to predict that
they're going to get value from you
later is to give them value before they
buy from you that's how it works now you
might be thinking well I don't want to
give away my valuable thing well the
alternative is that everyone thinks you
suck so of course you give away the
valuable thing and then you should also
have a very valuable paid thing all of
it has to be valuable and that's why
business is heart because you have to
provide value all the way through